und seid bitte ganz ehrlich nicht als
bei dem ich mich oder so mühelos stimmt
schon so also wenn ihr nicht auf meiner
seite steht könnt ihr einen daumen nach
oben da lassen oder einen kommentar
schreiben
wenn ihr aber dagegen und will das
komplette scheiße
dann schreibt das auch so in die
kommentare auch wenn ich oft viel
scheiße jahre
leute was glaubt uns willkommen bei
neuen video kann ich jetzt schon ganz
viele von euch den titel gelesen aber
stopp um es zu verhindern dass wieder
etwa ankommen und meckern öl
du musst immer mädchen schlecht wartet
gut sollte wartet also mir ist in
letzter zeit hin und wieder aber
aufgefallen das mädchen schon so in den
einen oder anderen lebenssituationen
wirklich offensichtlich bevorzugt werden
ja ok klar jungs werden auch ab und zu
mal bevorzugen aber ich glaube da stehe
ich jetzt auch nicht so ganz andere da
bin ich ganz vorsichtig sage das mädchen
da schon so den kleinen vorteil im
vorteil haben also das mädchen halt
öfter bevorzugt werden als jungs
versteht ja okay ich gehe vorsichtig an
die sache ran ohne da jetzt wirklich
viel gemeckert ich sage euch einfach mal
was ich so davon halte aber eigentlich
richtig video auch wirklich nur weil es
mit aufgefallen ist und mich eure
meinung wirklich extrem interessiert ich
meine ich habe hauptsächlich weiblichen
zuschauer wie also die meisten das video
sehen sind weiblich von daher schreibt
eure meinung direkt mal dazu und in die
kommentare
also wenn ich irgendwas dran stellt
direkt kommentar und seid bitte ganz
ehrlich nicht als weil die mich mögen
oder sony nutzt du bestimmt schon so
eine wenn ihr denkt auf meiner seite
steht könnt ihr gerne daumen nach oben
da lassen oder einen kommentar schreiben
wenn ihr aber dagegen seit unserer
kultur das komplette scheiße dann
schreibt das auch so in die kommentare
auch wenn ich oft viel scheiße ja wir
fangen jetzt mal so mit folgenden punkt
kann ich glaube habe ich auch schon mal
was zugesagt und zwar ganz einfach
schule klar es gibt wirklich lehrer die
bewährten so an sich fair aber es gibt
auch lehrer und das kann ich jetzt sagen
weil es mein kompletter größten teil so
sieht das halt mädchen schon bevorzugt
werden angenommen da sitzt jetzt mädchen
und das mädchen ist eigentlich wirklich
schlau es gibt ja viele mädchen die
wirklich schlau sind und sich dann noch
melden aber dieses mädchen sagt wirklich
gar nichts möglich und dann kriegen alle
leute ihre mündliche note die steht 2
und ihren den jungen der wirklich
andauernd mit macht steht schlechter ich
meine wo ist da das ihnen das kennen
doch das kann doch eigentlich alle von
euch oder logischer weise könnte man
jetzt erschließen okay wenn man jetzt
aber eine lehrerin hat dann werden die
jungen bevorzugt ist aber irgendwie auch
nicht so und ich denke wirklich manchmal
so in der schule wie so melde ich mich
wenn mir das eigentlich eh nix bringen
ich habe das ganze schon mal so ein
bisschen
google und männer auf so eine studie
gestoßen die irgendwie besorgt york also
mädchen werden in der schule schon
bevorzugt aber das liegt hauptsächlich
daran dass ist mehr lehrerinnen als
lehrer gibt aber er gibt doch auch
keinen sinn ich meinen setzten dann die
weiblichen oder ersetzt das weibliche
lehrpersonal das männliche lehrpersonal
so unter druck dass das männliche person
oder auch automatisch den schülern eine
schlechtere note gibt als den
schülerinnen wirklich eure meinung dazu
in die kommentare bitte seht ihr jetzt
komplett anders seht ihr das genauso
mich interessiert einfach ok kommen zum
nächsten wo man zwar dass es seit
bestimmt auch schon mal aufgefallen wenn
man so nach rorschach ist da sieht man
ja ab und zu obdachlose ist leider so
das gehört halt so dazu auch wenn es
traurig ist aber man sieht eigentlich
nur männliche obdachlos ich mein ich
persönlich find's gut eigentlich an sich
weil frauen tun mir automatisch schon
immer ein bisschen mehr leid wenn man
diese auf der straße als männer
naja ok das war jetzt irgendwie fast
eine antwort auf die frage wer also es
kann ja so sein dass jeder mensch
wirklich so denkt ach das ist eine frau
da habe ich automatisch mehr mitleid es
kann sein
ist das so über dieses thema mittel
obdachlose habe ich mich auch mal schlau
gemacht und zwar dann wirklich 80 der
opfer wurden auf der straße männer und
das liegt daran weil bei einer scheidung
im zweifelsfall immer der mann auch wenn
das haus sein eigentum ist verliert und
somit das haus an seine frau abgeben
muss und ab auf die straße wenn man halt
nicht so dann ist mir nur punkt
aufgefallen dass kein wirklich jeder
junge stellt euch bereits es irgendwas
zu erledigen sei es bücher tragen und da
steht ein junge und ein mädchen zur
verfügung und wenn dann gesagt wird ja
das macht jetzt mal der junge und man
als irgendwie nur warum muss ich das
jetzt schon wieder machen kann man so
eine antwort so interpretieren wie von
wegen ja das kannst du doch mal machen
ist doch nur so ein kleines armes
mädchen lucie prozess versteht ihr das
ist doch manchmal so oder ich will jetzt
auch keine nicht eingreifen also ok
eigentlich kann man als mädchen auch
froh sein wenn man so in den meisten
lebenssituationen bevorzugt werden oder
bevorteilt wird keine ahnung wie man das
jetzt nennt ja ich habe keine ahnung
warum ich jetzt hier zu einem video
gemacht habe es interessiert mich
einfach und ich habe darüber schon so
lange nachgedacht und deswegen wir euch
einfach mal fragen
schreibt eure meinung dazu einfach in
die kommentare egal weil er irgendwas
zum thema einfällt einfachen kommentar
schreiben ich bin ja gespannt ich werde
mega viele kommentare durchlese und auch
antworten denke ich mal und wenn sich
jetzt das eine oder andere mädchen
der hat mich jetzt grad blöd angemacht
das wollte ich nicht also endlich kann
man jetzt hier dann auch nicht schlimm
verstehen oder
also bleibt das dorf mit diesem video
gefallen nach oben da mal gucken wie
vieles drin sind ansatz ins fettnäpfchen
beides eingeladen könnt ihr gerne folgen
wenn ihr bock abonnieren nicht vergessen
die oben links ist weiter dass man seine
chatroulette mal wieder check das macht
mich freuen
ansonsten sehen wir uns am nächsten
bürgervertreter schönen sonntag noch